étranger
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le flux en direct d'inférence active
numéro 50.1 le 20 octobre 2022.
nous discutons de l'interception de papier
comme modélisation de l'allostase comme contrôle
bienvenue à l'
institut d'inférence active nous sommes un institut participatif en
ligne qui communique  apprendre
et pratiquer l'inférence active appliquée
ceci est enregistré dans un
flux en direct archivé, veuillez donc fournir des commentaires afin que nous
puissions améliorer notre travail
tous les horizons et perspectives sont les
bienvenus et suivront l'
étiquette vidéo pour les flux en direct, rendez
-vous sur
activeinference.org pour en savoir plus sur
comment s'impliquer dans différents
groupes d'apprentissage et projets comme les
flux en direct et sinon
nous sommes ici dans le flux en direct numéro 50.1
avec notre deuxième discussion sur l'
interception de papier en tant que modélisation de l'allostase comme
contrôle
auparavant, nous avions le numéro 50.0 où Dean
et moi avons fourni quelques informations de fond  et le
contexte et maintenant nous apprécions vraiment
que certains
auteurs se joignent pour le point un  et deux
pour décompresser et explorer quelques idées
et euh aujourd'hui ce sera formidable d'entendre
plusieurs auteurs voir une petite
présentation et plonger au milieu des
choses au cœur des choses comme nous le faisons dans
le point un
et donc nous commencerons par  introductions,
puis nous aurons une présentation
puis une discussion, nous commencerons donc par des
introductions avec des non-auteurs d'abord et
ils pourront se sentir libres de présenter dire bonjour
et tout ce qu'ils sont ravis d'
explorer aujourd'hui, donc je suis Daniel, je suis un
chercheur en Californie
et j'ai hâte de comprendre
certains des formalismes du modèle et
comment ils se connectent à l'inférence active et à
la mécanique bayésienne et je passerai à Dave
salut je suis Dave je suis
un
conservateur de discours um un étudiant de  Jacques le
punk et Mark soles J'habite dans la
ville universitaire de Baguio, à 200
kilomètres au nord de Manille Dean
merci Dave Je suis Dean Je suis à Calgary
euh
ce qui m'intéresse, c'est
qu'au niveau métaphorique, cela
m'a lancé dans un  dans un champ ouvert et j'ai eu  dans
une forêt et cette forêt est devenue plus dense et
bosselée et au moment où nous sommes arrivés à la section
quatre de cet article, j'ai commencé à le lire
encore et encore, ce qui est un
signe fantastique parce que si je dois lire quelque chose
plusieurs fois pour vraiment comprendre ma tête
autour de ça que
c'est bien parce que je ne remets pas en question les
choses à moins que je ne les comprenne pas cela
ne veut pas dire que ce n'était pas
énoncé correctement cela signifie simplement que vous avez attiré
mon attention alors
euh je ne sais pas quel auteur  pour le passer
à First peut-être Eli, vous voudriez
dire
bonjour à tous
euh je suis Eli je suis le premier auteur de cet
article
donc
euh un peu avant le début de la diffusion en direct
Jordan mentionnait que ce travail
sort de ce que nous  étions en quelque sorte
en train d'étudier ensemble dans notre laboratoire dans un
groupe de travail sur
l'énergétique groupe de lecture sur l'énergétique cérébrale avant que
la pandémie ne nous frappe vraiment
et donc quand j'étais
confiné,
vous savez que j'ai effectivement commencé à lire
et à relire, vous savez tout ce que
nous avions traversé et essayé de
monter  avec une certaine  façon
de penser à l'allostase parce que
dans notre groupe et dans nos publications précédentes en
tant que groupe Le
laboratoire de sciences affectives de l'acte interdisciplinaire, nous avons beaucoup fait référence à l'allostase
et chaque fois que je vous demanderais de savoir comment
pouvons-nous donner une caractérisation mathématique ou
informatique
de l'allostase I  serait essentiellement dit
bien,
vous savez, nous pensions que Peter Sterling en avait
un
, puis j'irais voir Peter
Sterling et
il est à l'origine du concept d'
allostase au fait, il y a donc de
nombreux travaux de lui sur le sujet
probablement la forme la plus longue
disons
non  -un traitement expert serait probablement
son livre qu'est-ce que la santé
hé
et quand je regarderais
le travail de Sterling, je repérerais en quelque sorte une
contradiction ou une contradiction dans les
termes l'
un d'un côté,
il trace spécifiquement la variation
des paramètres physiologiques et de la
régulation au
fil du temps où  le temps peut être le cours
d'une vie au cours du
développement ou même juste le cours d'une
seule journée
et pourtant sur  d'un autre côté, si vous lui demandez
bien comment cela se fait, il dirait
effectivement
euh que cela se fait par apprentissage par renforcement
via les systèmes dopaminergiques dans
le cerveau
maintenant les systèmes dopaminergiques dans le
cerveau ne suivent pas un signal changeant au fil du
temps, ils maximisent simplement la récompense
et donc en fait, à mon avis, au moins en tant
qu'informaticien, ils étaient plus
homéostatiques qu'allostatiques
et de cette contradiction et ce qui
en a découlé est vraiment devenu
tout cet article
étranger,
mais pour souligner à nouveau, je dirais et
avant de sauter dans vous savez le
matériel des diapositives  à l'intérieur de l'article,
je pense qu'il vaut vraiment la peine de souligner
simplement en regardant le
flux en direct 50.0 que
notre groupe est plus, disons, des biologistes
et des physiologistes en orientation que des
physiciens,
donc bayésien, l'article sur la
mécanique bayésienne est sorti pendant que nous écrivions
ceci
et je ne le fais pas  pense que nous avons vraiment réussi à
intégrer les deux ensembles de matériel
ensemble
ou ensemble mais
cela ne veut pas dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas ou
ne devraient pas être  intégré, c'est-à-dire que
nous n'avons pas en fait pour
ainsi dire, nous n'avons pas toujours l'
expertise en physique et en systèmes dynamiques
de quelqu'un comme Thomas Parr ou Maxwell
Ramstead, sans parler de Karl Kristen, d'un
autre côté,
nous avons des notions très concrètes de ce que la
biologie et  La physiologie que nous devons adapter
à la majeure partie de cet article, vous
savez que la raison pour laquelle ce n'est pas seulement une courte
section avec des mathématiques,
c'est parce que nous devons nous adapter à la
physiologie et à l'anatomie que nous connaissons,
merci Jordan, n'hésitez pas à intro et
puis Eli à vous pour une
présentation à coup sûr, donc je suis un
post-doctorant dans le laboratoire ici, donc je pense que je vais peut-être
juste donner un peu de contexte sur où
nous travaillons tous les deux aussi et comment nous en sommes arrivés
là donc
pour moi  J'ai eu un chemin un peu étrange pour
arriver à ce point dans la mesure où j'ai fait mon doctorat
en psychologie sociale et en psychologie morale
euh
c'est alors euh une sorte de trans s'est vraiment
vraiment intéressé aux
perspectives de traitement prédictif et à l'
inférence active et ensuite vraiment voulu  creuse
je  nto cela et trouver quelqu'un qui travaille
dessus ici à Boston euh donc je
travaille avec Lisa Feldman Barrett et
Karen rapidement qui co-dirigent le
laboratoire interdisciplinaire de sciences affectives
ici
euh et comme vous les gars disant que la
perspective que nous avons est vraiment plus
d'un ou plusieurs
biologiquement fondés sur la physiologie
et les neurosciences. Alors Lisa et Carol plaisantent en
disant que Lisa gère en quelque sorte tout
du cou vers le haut et Karen gère
tout du cou vers le bas, donc
ensemble, ils forment une personne entière
euh
et quoi  ce que j'ai vraiment eu de la chance de faire,
c'est que je suis tombé sur
euh
une collaboration existante qui
a duré environ une décennie ici
euh que nous appelons le
groupe de neurosciences de l'ingénierie psychologique ou le
groupe de plumes
où il y a eu une
collaboration continue avec euh des professeurs en
génie électrique  département
probablement le plus important Dana Brooks
a vraiment beaucoup aidé à le faire fonctionner que
Dennis abdogmas et Jennifer D ont
également été l  ike vraiment vraiment impliqué dans
ce
euh
et donc ce qu'ils feraient, c'est qu'ils se rencontraient
chaque semaine et ils s'en sortiraient en quelque sorte
sur des papiers d'intérêt actif
traitant des papiers euh Théorie de l'information
ils nous
mettraient tous au courant, nous les neuroscientifiques
comprendre l'ingénierie et nous essayons de les
mettre au courant d'une sorte de
compréhension biologique des neurosciences
aussi, donc
ce qui nous intéresse vraiment,
c'est de
penser à certaines des abstractions
qui sont apparues dans l'acte de
littérature d'inférence  et réfléchir à la façon
de fonder ces processus biologiques
euh et comment vraiment rendre cela gérable
à un niveau biologique empirique et donc
l'intérêt que j'ai eu pour l'
énergétique cérébrale a été
euh un moyen d'appliquer une partie de cette traction
sur euh
mon intérêt d'origine  qui est une sorte de
normes morales et sociales, j'ai donc fait un
peu de travail sur la
façon dont nous pouvons penser à l'
information ou aux coûts énergétiques du traitement de l'
information comme un moyen  de euh
comment les individus exercent un contrôle sur un
environnement social en se conformant aux
attentes qu'il contient
et puis en même temps j'ai été
intéressé à aller à l'autre bout
et à penser à euh certains des
détails du métabolisme cérébral et du
métabolisme du glucose cérébral qui sont  associé
au signal Bold fmri afin que nous puissions
vraiment creuser plus profondément dans le
métabolisme qui sous-tend l'
imagerie neuronale leur image dans la littérature,
euh, mais en train de
réaliser cela ou de former ce
groupe de lecture énergétique où nous
avons creusé dans tous  ces sujets pour
essayer de comprendre la biologie du cerveau
Eli et moi avons vraiment fini par travailler
ensemble dans cet article pour essayer d'appliquer à nouveau une
partie de ce
travail énergétique et biologique
avec une tonne d'aide de Karen
et Lisa qui connaissent vraiment les détails
de  la neuroscience et la physiologie réelle,
je pense que Karen en particulier
qu'Eli dirait probablement a été comme
vraiment vraiment vraiment critique pour l'
ONU  comprendre ces systèmes physiologiques
euh
mais fondamentalement ouais comment nous pouvons
avoir certains des paramètres et
hypothèses de ces modèles d'inférence active
fondés sur des termes biologiques réels que
nous pouvons commencer à consulter la littérature empirique la
littérature biologique biologique
et en quelque sorte
s'inspirer davantage de  que plutôt que de
vivre entièrement à un niveau abstrait
cool et avec ça je vais le remettre à
Eli
excellent d'accord
je n'ai pas partagé n'hésitez pas à y aller
merci pour ce contexte
et juste à noter
euh ça a fait
euh cet article  apporte certains
sujets que nous n'avons abordés dans aucun
des 50 articles précédents,
dont beaucoup étaient également des facteurs de motivation de
ce que vous avez
décidé d'explorer, donc je vais juste recadrer en
redimensionnant et ainsi de suite et Eli, s'il vous plaît, allez-
y  bon
euh
donc avant d'entrer vraiment dans le sujet
de l'article, je pense qu'il pourrait être utile
de suivre ce que Jordan a dit
afin de motiver davantage
notre virage vers la biologie  et la physiologie
ici
qui est que la plupart du temps la
modélisation d'inférence inactive
notez que je dis modélisation ou une
physique stagiaire active pour ainsi dire
vous avez besoin d'un terme dans votre énergie libre attendue
ou dans votre densité articulaire
qui est désolé la densité articulaire générative
pas la reconnaissance  celui que
vous appelleriez souvent, je l'ai entendu
appeler les préférences antérieures
essentiellement une densité de probabilité sur
les résultats sensoriels qui décrit ce
qu'il est difficile d'éviter le
langage anthropomorphique ici, mais bon ce que vous
voulez observer
maintenant dans de vrais systèmes biologiques que vous
connaissez comme nous  en quelque sorte peut entendre Peter
Sterling
ou de nombreux autres auteurs qui ne peuvent pas être
corrigés,
c'est-à-dire que vous savez que les préférences antérieures
ne peuvent pas être corrigées, c'est moi Je préfère
des observations différentes lorsque je suis sur le point
de m'endormir par rapport à quand je me réveille
et  l'hypothèse qui est généralement
intégrée à des
principes comme, par exemple, le principe de l'énergie libre
est qu'en
fait, laissez-moi modérer cela un peu en
fonction de la conversation  s avec certains
principes d'énergie libre
si vous avez une formulation non basée sur un chemin d'accès une
formulation basée sur l'état du
principe d'énergie libre, vous supposerez généralement
quelque chose appelé ergotisme
et vous remarquerez que nous avons une annexe
sur l'ergotisme j'ai vu que vous avez
discuté  la semaine dernière dans l'épisode du point zéro
merci d'avoir saisi
cela et merci à tous les
spectateurs et à l'auditoire qui ont compris
que
l'hypothèse d'ergodicité
vous permet essentiellement d'échanger l'incertitude sur le
temps ou sur la durée contre l'incertitude du
moment
donc vous pouvez simplement dire qu'il y a une
densité de préférence a priori gaussienne,
elle a autant de précision ou autant de
variance selon la
manière dont vous préférez mettre votre
signe de division
, puis
c'est la même chose pour tous les temps
maintenant si vous faites un chemins-  formule basée sur la
formulation,
vous perdez le lien entre le
principe de l'énergie libre et
les notions physiologiques conventionnelles d'
homéostasie
car maintenant, après tout, le point de consigne ne peut
pas être  tout ou tout
ce dont vous avez besoin de savoir quelque chose sur la
physiologie L'anatomie pour le lier
et c'est donc vraiment la motivation dont
nous venons dans cet article est que
si vous devez acquérir ou apprendre des
préférences antérieures tout au long du développement,
combien peu pouvez-vous intégrer
et ainsi de suite  nous commençons par passer en revue dans
l'article et dans ces diapositives le type
de perspectives que nous étudions à partir de l'étude
du système nerveux étudier le cerveau l'
un d'eux est le traitement prédictif, je
pense que ce sera probablement le plus
important pour ce public et dans le
prédictif  traitement, nous parlons
des systèmes perceptifs du cerveau, en fait
des systèmes sensoriels
comme effectuant une inférence bayésienne approximative,
vous aurez donc des signaux de prédiction descendants, des
signaux d'erreur de prédiction ascendants
et il y a cette notion d'inférence active
qui dit que nous traitons essentiellement
moteur  sorties
comme paramètres du modèle de reconnaissance
dans l'une de ses dans l'une des premières
formulations avant qu'il n'y ait
énergie libre attendue
Mais finalement, il est toujours dit dans toute
formulation nouvelle ou récente que nous avons une
notion d'erreur de prédiction
entre les densités et qu'il s'agit d'une
quantité théorique d'information,
donc nous parlons vraiment d'une
divergence ou d'une entropie ou d'une entropie croisée que
nous voulons minimiser  cela et nous
n'allons pas seulement minimiser cela en modifiant
les prédictions descendantes qui
traversent, disons, le cortex sensoriel, nous
allons également modifier ces
paramètres supplémentaires qui correspondent aux
prédictions motrices motrices commandes motrices références motrices en
fonction de la terminologie que
vous  nous voulons utiliser pour nous y
référer, alors dans notre laboratoire où nous sommes en quelque sorte des
biologistes de l'émotion,
nous étudions souvent l'interception
et c'est vraiment une
définition assez vague sur la diapositive ici
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de débats parmi les
neuroanatomistes sur le type d'
interception  se termine et la réception x-star
commence dont les modalités exactes doivent être
classées dans quel sens ou dans un autre
mais vraiment l'interception est st  s'il s'agit d'un
ensemble ou d'une catégorie de modalités sensorielles
et quand je dis modalités sensorielles, je
mentionne cela précisément parce que la
littérature sur l'inférence active interceptive a
alors tendance à prendre ce que nous pourrions appeler
la forme la plus ancienne d'inférence active,
elle prend le chemin de la forme la plus ancienne
d'inférence active.  inférence active disant j'ai une
densité générative j'ai une
action de densité de reconnaissance devient effectivement un paramètre
pour ajuster la densité de reconnaissance à la
densité générative
et il n'y a pas vraiment de notion de
modèle génératif interne qui
soit séparé qui sépare la croyance et le
désir
donc dans  une grande partie de la littérature sur l'
inférence active interceptive,
vous trouverez des références à des priors très
précis
ou même vous connaissez des priors innés sur
les paramètres interceptifs
et vous verrez cette notion que
vous utilisez l'inférence active dans le
domaine interceptif plus que vous ne l'utilisez
dans  le domaine somatique
parce que vous essayez d'adapter votre
physiologie interne à une notion de point de
consigne a priori  ts qui sont déterminés
par l'évolution
pensez-vous que vous pourriez donner un exemple
de cela Eli et quel genre de points de consigne les
gens pourraient
penser bien
voyons voir j'ai vu
les niveaux de dioxyde de carbone dans le sang
les niveaux de glucose mentionnés
um la température corporelle centrale est vraiment le
celui auquel j'ai tendance à revenir car il
reste vraiment constant la plupart du
temps,
il peut varier, mais c'est vraiment un
type de situation inextremis,
donc si vous pensez à la température corporelle centrale,
il y a un circuit et je pense que vous savez que
Jordan me corrige si je  Je me trompe, mais
c'est encore une fois le NTS, n'est-ce pas
les facteurs du noyau
ouais d'accord ouais
euh essentiellement dans le tronc cérébral, il y a
un circuit qui code le
point de consigne typique pour la température corporelle centrale
et d'un point de vue d'inférence active,
vous pourriez dire que c'est un  probabilité fixe,
il ne peut pas être reparamétré
par une prédiction provenant de plus
haut
ou plutôt la plupart du temps, il n'est pas
reparamétré de
sorte que cela coule comme une prédiction et
le  n chaque capteur de température dans le
corps
peut comparer la température réelle à
la température souhaitée
calculer une
erreur de prédiction pondérée de précision entre eux
renvoyer ces erreurs
et ensuite le cerveau peut dire aha je dois
trouver un moyen de minimiser ces erreurs
et cela gardera efficacement
vous dans un environnement où vous pouvez
maintenir votre température corporelle centrale
autour de
vous savez que je pense que c'est 98,6 Fahrenheit est
le stéréotype
qui varie pour les individus
maintenant la raison pour laquelle ma prochaine diapositive concernait l'
allostase
est
parce qu'il existe des paramètres pétillants comme la
température centrale
qui se comportent généralement selon  à un
point de consigne
vraiment physiologiquement la plupart des paramètres
n'ont pas de point de consigne
ils bougent les niveaux régulés bougent tout
le temps,
ce qui inclut la fréquence cardiaque
la pression artérielle la
glycémie les niveaux d'oxygène dans le sang
divers niveaux d'hormones dans les systèmes endocriniens
les niveaux d'inflammation
changent avec le temps
et j'ai mentionné  inflammation parce que
vous savez du point de vue du corps qu'il y a
C'est que vous savez que l'inflammation n'est pas
quelque chose avec un point de consigne de zéro
inflammation est parfois approprié
et en fait si vous voulez penser que vous
savez quelle est la situation dans laquelle l'
adaptation de tous ces paramètres de base
est physiologiquement adaptative,
alors
je pense que
l'exercice physique intense et la maladie
sont  probablement les deux plus grands exemples,
donc pour un exercice intense, nous pourrions parler,
par
exemple, des niveaux d'excitation
et cela fait référence à l'équilibre de
l'activité coopérative dans les branches
du système nerveux autonome,
mais essentiellement si vous
allez courir,
disons d'un prédateur ou  après un peu de nourriture
dans votre fille façonnée, vous savez l'
environnement ancestral Evo psych,
vous allez devoir diminuer l'
activité dans certains systèmes d'organes, augmenter
l'activité dans d'autres systèmes d'organes
et ajuster les
paramètres physiologiques à réguler aux nouveaux
niveaux,
donc c'est une jolie  fait de physiologie bien observé que
vous connaissez officieusement
Peter Sterling je dirais avoir
inventé l'allostase comme observation
cela se fait,
il
éditorialise ensuite un peu à ce sujet et
dit qu'il devrait remplacer l'
homéostasie comme mode de régulation,
donc plutôt que d'avoir des points de consigne, vous
devriez comparer à quelque chose comme une
trajectoire définie
et dans le cas idéal lorsque vous
théorisez, vous devriez  supposons qu'il n'y
a pas de
point de consigne global d'aucun paramètre
et bien sûr, comme nous l'avons mentionné précédemment dans les
extrémistes, cela est vrai si vous tombez malade,
votre corps remplace réellement ce
circuit dans le tronc cérébral
pour augmenter la température centrale, c'est pourquoi
vous aurez des frissons  vous êtes à la même
température
mais le niveau régulé a été décalé
il y a aussi un
point intéressant à faire si vous revenez en arrière une seconde
vous aimez juste ça euh dans la façon dont
le genre de langage scientifique évolue
ici aussi et  cela vaut la peine de le souligner
car certaines personnes pourraient écouter
et penser que
vous savez bien que l'homéostasie n'a pas besoin
d'inclure des points de consigne non plus vous pouvez
avoir une sorte d'océan d'or plus élevé  uponio
stasis vous pouvez avoir euh vous savez une sorte de
plusieurs niveaux de contrôle impliqués dans
cela et certaines personnes ont fait la même
critique de l'allostase en tant qu'océan, il
y a donc un article de Carpenter
par Carpenter qui fait exactement cela,
donc
c'est
mais le problème est  est-ce que même si
c'est comme ça, c'est techniquement vrai et que les
gens qui savent vraiment ce qu'ils
font et utilisent un concept d'
homéostasie de cette manière pourraient déjà
comprendre que vous n'avez pas nécessairement
besoin de points de consigne,
mais la réalité est que la façon
l'homéostasie a tendance à être utilisée de la manière
dont elle a tendance à être comprise, c'est qu'elle en est
venue à avoir une partie de cette association
avec des points de consigne ou avec un
modèle de thermostat simple par opposition à quelque chose de
plus large qui comprend plusieurs niveaux de
contrôle et donc
certaines personnes qui pourraient être  certaines personnes
pourraient être curmudgeoni et vouloir dire
que l'homéostasie inclut déjà toutes
ces notions, nous devrions donc simplement récupérer
le terme homéostasie pour cela,
je pense que nous sommes  plus de la perspective
que nous sommes prêts à abandonner cela
et il serait peut-être temps de commencer à utiliser
un terme différent pour rappeler aux gens
ces autres associations, donc
nous ensemençons un peu le terrain
lorsque nous utilisons  le terme allostase
pour ne pas avoir à se battre avec les gens
sur ce que signifie vraiment l'homéostasie
oui donc Jordan a tout à fait raison
là-bas mais je recommanderais même en fait
que vous sachiez que tout le monde
écoute si vous pouvez aller trouver le papier
homéostasie un plaidoyer pour une
approche unifiée par rhs  Carpenter, c'est dans nos
citations et vous devriez pouvoir taper
le nom dans Google Scholar, allez le regarder
car cela expliquera vraiment d'où vient notre
article en
tant que bref résumé de ce qui est pertinent,
ce que Carpenter dit dans son article est que de
retour dans  Au bon vieux temps, ils enseignaient
la théorie du contrôle et l'ingénierie des contrôles
aux physiologistes et cela incluait
vous connaissez des physiologistes de recherche et aussi des
cliniciens
et à l'époque, il voulait vraiment dire de
retour comme  les années 1940 aux années 1960
avant qu'une autre nouvelle approche ne prenne le relais
et elle dit hé si vous êtes un ingénieur en contrôle instruit,
mathématiquement mature et fluide
, vous n'avez pas besoin
de savoir que ces noms gênants ne
sont tous que des façons différentes de
couper le même gâteau
vous savez que tout est un système de contrôle, c'est
un système de contrôle hiérarchique, c'est
très évident, dit-il dans l'anatomie et la
physiologie que vous regarderez,
il écrit même pour un
journal d'éducation en physiologie
, puis il commence effectivement à se
plaindre que vous savez que tout le monde est une
sorte de paille  l'homéostasie habitée jusqu'à
ce modèle de thermostat
et il doit se plaindre comme ça en 2004
parce qu'en effet tout le monde a
vraiment associé le mot homéostasie à
ce modèle de thermostat Points de consigne globaux
comme la température corporelle plutôt que
la glycémie
et par conséquent
il
y a en conséquence  une grande partie de la
théorie du contrôle réel a été
simplifiée,
même si quelqu'un est hébergé dans un
département d'informatique  a pris un cours
sur l'apprentissage par renforcement et peut travailler
les équations de la théorie du contrôle optimal
Je n'ai pas été initié au concept d'un
signal de référence en
tant que fonction variable dans le temps
jusqu'à Carpenter
et c'était en fait assez révélateur
pour moi que plutôt que d'avoir une
fonction d'erreur
qui est
vous  connaître le minimum dont le minimum global
est fixé pour toujours
vous pouvez avoir une fonction d'erreur qui
mesure la différence entre votre
trajectoire réelle
et une trajectoire souhaitée vous pouvez effectuer un
contrôle de suivi de trajectoire lorsque vous
avez les mathématiques
afin que nous puissions dire pour notre article à nos
fins si  l'homéostasie fait référence à ce
contrôle de suivi de point de style de thermostat de thermiostat,
puis l'allostase fait référence au
contrôle de suivi de trajectoire,
donc avancez un peu et
revenez sur la voie principale
de nos points de vue informés par la
physiologie et l'anatomie
et un peu d'
interception evodivo et d'allostase ont Pro
ont  les deux se sont
assez bien révélés
être
vraiment centraux  à la façon dont le système nerveux
est réellement structuré
et apparemment largement concerné par
le métabolisme et le fonctionnement déficient
des viscères,
donc pour tous ceux qui veulent connaître les
citations pour cela, je pense que c'est
euh Jordan ce serait Barrett et qui
2015.
oh euh Barrett et Simmons 2015  . oui
Article de neurosciences ouais revues de la nature
Les
prédictions d'interception des neurosciences dans le cerveau
il y a une revue plus récente écrite par
Karen Quigley notre autre auteur principal
sur l'interception est sortie en 2021
et donc vous pouvez vraiment aller vérifier par
vous-même et je lui conseillerais à quel point
Central dans  la réception terrestre et la régulation viscérale
sont empiriquement liées au système nerveux,
vous pourriez éventuellement concevoir un
système nerveux pour un robot qui fonctionnait
différemment, mais ceux qui ont évolué
sont omniprésents centrés sur le maintien
de l'efficacité de la milia interne du corps,
alors
euh oui
euh Dan chatouille ouais ça te dérange  si je
décidais d'une question rapide ici bien sûr
ouais parce que euh les deux auteurs ici
peuvent peut-être  confirmez simplement que mon parachute
est correctement emballé, c'est ce avec quoi je veux
essentiellement
être à l'aise, alors
reculez d'une seconde
dans cette diapositive pour que vous dirigez simplement
la chaîne et la trame ici le type
de tissage que vous  les gars travaillaient
sur cet article était l'allostase et l'entéroception,
c'étaient vos points focaux,
et puis vous avez
passé pas mal de temps à nous préparer
à la différence entre l'
aspect temporel discret de ce que vous cherchez  à
et le taux de capture global parce que vous
dites que nous ne pouvons pas nous ne pouvons pas être réparés et
juste celui qui dit que je veux m'assurer que mon
tournage est correctement emballé et ensuite vous
parlez de biologie et de physiologie donc
juste là-dessus  ce grand gros vais-je
aller Splat ou vais-je
pouvoir atterrir relativement doucement pouvez-
vous peut-être juste
me dire si c'est en fait ou non
est-ce une comparaison est-ce une intersection
est-ce que ces choses fonctionnent en parallèle
combien de  c'est la gestion des risques par rapport à
la mesure dans laquelle cela est stratégique,
je le considérerais davantage comme
une intersection d'accord et lorsque nous nous
référons spécifiquement à des quantités
comme le taux de capture global,
celles-ci sont destinées à être stratégiques
plutôt que la gestion des risques ou la valeur épistémique d'
accord
donc  spécifiquement là-
bas, il y a un livre entier à ce sujet, disons-le
um Vigor la
neuroéconomie du contrôle du mouvement par Reza shadmir
et il chronique sous une forme très longue de manière
approfondie la preuve empirique
que
les organismes réels feront la moyenne de leur
taux de récompense
dans le temps afin de passer d'un épisodique
réglage sur un
réglage continu, vous savez sur un réglage continu à
vie,
vous avez besoin d'une notion de contrôle à durée indéterminée,
évidemment, vous n'allez pas vivre jusqu'à ce que
T vous sachiez que T atteigne l'infini,
mais à la limite, vous devez avoir un
problème de contrôle cohérent
à  moins à des fins de modélisation parce que
vous ne pouvez pas
fixer la fin de la vie d'un oiseau
dans le laboratoire sur un ordinateur portable d'accord
et il y a deux façons de conve  ntionnellement, pour
faire cela, l'un est cette notion de
Dieu et mettre le taux de capture global de
sorte que le temps moyen soit
la somme de tous les avantages moins la
somme de tous les coûts divisée par le temps total
et l'autre est une actualisation exponentielle
maintenant à des fins d'ingénierie
actualisation exponentielle  rend les mathématiques
et les calculs beaucoup plus faciles à gérer
et donc au début des années 2000, ils ont
essentiellement découvert que le vrai que vous connaissez, les
vrais cerveaux
comme les ganglions de la base que vous connaissez et
le déclenchement dopaminergique
sont mieux adaptés par la moyenne temporelle
, puis du côté informatique,
tout le monde l'a ignoré et l'a fait
actualisation exponentielle
et donc vraiment quand nous parlons de
quelque chose comme un taux de capture global,
nous disons simplement que nous allons avec les
preuves biologiques et écrivons un
modèle qui tient le mieux compte
des liaisons empiriques que
vous savez si vous voulez citer sans guillemets
essayez ceci  à la maison, vous êtes parfaitement
invités à passer à
la remise exponentielle
c'est bien ou à la
communauté d'apprentissage automatique  commence à sortir des
articles sur la moyenne du temps,
vous savez ces dernières années
et c'est une question rapide de plus, alors
bien sûr, merci pour
cette explication, donc si nous
posons la question de la
traçabilité  cela suppose qu'il y a
une sorte de glissance ou
de fluidité dans cette chose que
nous examinons qu'est-ce que c'est
quoi cette chose
qui est fluide qui est glissante qui
nous empêche normalement de
modéliser est-ce une caractéristique ou est  qu'un
défaut
je dirais que la glissance est la
glissance qui est le glissement entre la carte
et le territoire d'
accord
donc quand on parle de vrais cerveaux
on sait qu'on observe une moyenne temporelle
sur le territoire
ce qu'on ne sait pas faire c'est écrire un
algorithme
qui  produit de manière prouvée une moyenne de temps correcte
et fonctionne dans la pratique en ingénierie d'
accord,
alors disons même plutôt que carte et
territoire parce que le scientifique a également une
carte
disons que le glissement est entre  n
science empirique et ingénierie
et lorsque nous écrivons notre modèle, nous
essayons vraiment d'aborder la
science empirique et cela ne nous dérange pas si les ingénieurs que
vous connaissez veulent faire leur petit
dérapage et
utiliser quelque chose qui facilite simplement l'
algorithmique
c'est bien
vous savez  et en fait c'est ce que fait la
communauté d'inférence active profonde,
alors revenons un peu plus
vers l'inférence active
lorsque nous lisons tout cela, c'est
une sorte de Bible pour notre laboratoire
Sterling et Laughlin,
donc Simon Laughlin était impliqué dans  certaines
des premières publications sur le
codage prédictif dans la rétine de la mouche
Peter Sterling est à l'origine du
concept d'allostase
et ce que nous remarquons en fait,
comme mentionné un peu plus tôt, c'est ce genre
de glissement, un autre glissement ou
contradiction,
alors ils disent que lorsque vous obtenez une récompense certains
la dopamine est libérée
cela invoque un algorithme principal d'apprentissage par renforcement
vous savez soyons prudent avec les
circuits neuronaux que nous n'étudions pas  ng en
détail pour le
moment, soyons prudents à quel point
nous faisons une déclaration solide sur leur fonction
, puis la plupart des preuves empiriques
qu'ils examinent dans le livre concernent l'
efficacité énergétique du tir sensoriel
, nous essayons donc vraiment de dire que nous voulons
passer de
quelque chose fondé sur la minimisation d'une
inférence variationnelle d'erreur de prédiction
à quelque chose fondé
idéalement sur un principe d'optimalité dans le
contrôle, il y a donc des arguments pour les
neuroscientifiques
qui sont plus ou moins destinés à
convaincre le neuroscientifique d'Ewing que les
gens qui étudient l'interception et ceux qui
étudient les neurosciences motrices
besoin de travailler ensemble pour étudier les
viscères
vous ne pouvez pas étudier les viscères et ignorer
la branche motrice du système nerveux viscéral
et les fonctions de cette branche motrice
maintenant en ce qui concerne vous connaissez notre déclaration selon laquelle
vous ne pouvez pas simplement minimiser l'erreur de prédiction que l'
on pourrait demander  qu'en est-il de l'inférence active
et
là, nous devons commencer à faire attention
au terme actif dans  férence
parce que vous savez, comme je l'ai
personnellement expliqué en détail,
il y a au moins les deux
types différents d'inférence active
il y a ce très vieux
euh je pense que c'était Adams 2013.
vous savez que les prédictions d'inférence active motrice
ne commandent pas l'
inférence active dans le  moteur que
vous connaissez dans le système moteur
et puis il y a cette notion d'inférence active de décision
où vous avez une énergie libre attendue des
préférences antérieures explicites et ainsi de suite et
ainsi de suite
et si vous parlez à la
communauté d'inférence active,
vous savez lire les articles qu'ils peuvent
écrire  pour leur propre communauté,
je vous recommanderais particulièrement de connaître
l'atelier international sur l'
inférence active qui, je pense, sera
une conférence l'année prochaine,
ils ont trois ans de très bons
articles où de nombreux auteurs esquissent les
liens explicites entre
le contrôle d'inférence active en tant qu'inférence
optimale  contrôle
Etc
donc vraiment quand nous disons que vous
savez ne pas utiliser l'inférence active pour
réduire les fonctions motrices  sur la
fonction sensorielle,
nous parlons à des psychologues et des
philosophes
qui ont été
, disons, assez enthousiastes à propos du
traitement prédictif
mais un peu éliminativistes à propos de certaines
des constructions mathématiques qui sont
réellement utilisées dans l'inférence active
, alors pour notre public de psychologues,
nous avons encore une fois  l'argument selon lequel nous
montrons fondamentalement que vous pouvez et devez faire
une notion entièrement probabiliste de
contrôle optimal afin de trier ce qui se passe
avec la régulation allostatique
et nous allons nous inspirer
de la neuroanatomie motrice pour le
faire.
un système modèle simple
et cela entre dans les chiffres de
l'article
nous avons notre courbe de réponse afférente du réflexe barillet
vous avez un barorécepteur carotté c'est dans
l'artère carotide dans le cou
il mesure la pression artérielle
projette vers un circuit dans le
euh NTS dans le tronc cérébral
et nous évoquons cela ici parce que le
récepteur baril est souvent utilisé comme modèle
en terrasse
quand je parle  d à Karen et a demandé des
modèles de systèmes d'interception,
elle a en fait dit que vous savez bien,
pensons d'abord au récepteur de puissance
et encore une fois avec contradiction,
ce que nous trouvons réellement en regardant l'
anatomie, c'est que le barorécepteur le
récepteur du baril carotidien
est la branche sensorielle d'un bas  -circuit de
contrôle de niveau
afin que le NTS n'ait alors
pas, je crois, le
point d'inflexion médian
est codé dans le NTS ici et ne change pas
vraiment beaucoup, mais ce qui se passe,
c'est que vous pouvez obtenir des commandes descendantes
circulant dans le MTS
, puis changer le  gain de ce
circuit de
sorte que la pente de la courbe
et si vous élargissez cette pente de
sorte que la courbe soit moins profonde
que votre réactivité préservée,
vous restez, vous élargissez la
partie approximativement linéaire de la
courbe
tout en permettant à la pression artérielle d'
augmenter et  tomber
et donc encore une fois on voit pour l'interception des
gens
auxquels il faut vraiment réfléchir tu
sais quel est le rôle de cet
Intercepteur dans le contrôle
du corps et  des viscères,
vous ne pouvez pas simplement le regarder et dire que c'est un
capteur, d'accord, c'est un capteur où
est-ce que l'informatique se projette sur le
cortex entéroceptif non non pas
nécessairement comme vous connaissez l'erreur les
signaux d'erreur de prédiction qui atteignent le
cortex interceptif
pour dire que vous savez  Je ne peux pas pomper suffisamment de
sang ou quelque chose comme ça
pourrait déjà avoir été
traité par
ce que je crois dans la
littérature d'inférence active du moteur est appelé un arc réflexe
donc il pourrait déjà y avoir un reflet d'un
contrôleur réflexe qui a fonctionné sur
ce signal par le  le temps qu'il atteigne les
parties supérieures du cerveau,
donc dans notre article, nous avons défini un
vocabulaire que les gens peuvent utiliser s'ils
veulent
ne pas avoir à
courbe de capacité en particulier, nous allons le
lier à la notion de la
fonction de distribution cumulative  plus
tard,
il y a une terminologie de physiologie pour les
personnes qui veulent l'apprendre
, puis nous notons la même chose que
Carpenter fait
Carpenter et un certain nombre d'autres articles, à savoir
qu'il s'agit d'un ma  système de contrôle hiérarchiquement hiérarchique
,
de nombreuses substances réglementées, disons,
ou des variables régulées vont avoir
plusieurs contrôleurs qui les influencent,
par exemple,
les niveaux de nutriments dans le sang, pas seulement le glucose,
mais je pense que l'eau salée et
grasse
est régulée par des paires d'hormones,
parfois il y aura plusieurs paires
de  hormones par nutriment qui doivent être
dans le sang
et ce n'est pas un compromis convexe, donc
ce n'est pas une régulation concurrentielle antagoniste
,
ils peuvent parfois sembler être en concurrence,
mais en fait c'est une régulation coopérative
basée sur le fait que pour ainsi dire
les espèces chimiques ne peuvent pas  encoder des
nombres négatifs comme un signal numérique peut
donc lorsque vous faites des choses avec des
signaux chimiques ayant ces paires s'avère
être le moyen de
surveiller et de contrôler la plage dynamique
avec la plus grande sensibilité
comme alors en utilisant cet exemple de glucagon
et d'insuline,
nous pouvons voir  ce genre de glycémie normale
est vraiment plus une plage
et c'est une plage où vous allez
avoir  réponse approximativement linéaire de
l'activité de l'insuline
et vous allez avoir saturé
ou vraiment vous allez avoir
limité l'activité du glucagon,
donc à un niveau normal de sucre dans le sang, le
glucagon n'a pas à récupérer de
sucre dans le sang supplémentaire des
intestins ou du foie
il n'a pas besoin d'appeler pour brûler les graisses
.
Vous réserve essentiellement que vous avez assez mangé pour
le jour où vous allez bien. l'
insuline est réactive dans un
mode très réactif où elle peut donner une
réponse linéaire à un changement linéaire
afin de compenser le bruit.
alors maintenant nous pouvons réellement nous rapprocher de vous
savez maintenant que nous avons une façon de contrôler la
physiologie,
nous pouvons aller plus vers ces notions d'
inférence active
et ici nous allons revenir à certaines
des
sources qui nous ont donné moteur actif  inférence
une façon de penser à l'inférence active motrice
est
le sens cérébral de la prédiction
l'arc réflexe dans la moelle épinière
tente de minimiser l'erreur de prédiction
en comparant la prédiction avec e  La
valeur lue d'un propriocepteur,
donc encore une fois, une façon d'y penser
est d'avoir quelques façons supplémentaires de minimiser
l'erreur de prédiction vraiment l'entropie
une autre façon d'y penser
est de penser à avoir un
système de contrôle très élémentaire au niveau de l'arc réflexe
, puis  le cerveau prescrit la
longueur de référence qui est le
signal de référence pour ce contrôleur
et il essaie simplement de minimiser la
différence entre ce qu'il obtient d'un
propriocepteur ce qu'il lit la
longueur et la tension réelles du muscle
et le signal de référence
et c'est en fait un très I I  'd presque
appeler cela un circuit amusant à étudier à
cause de la façon dont il est bien documenté
qu'il y a quelque chose de très semblable,
je dirais presque comme un
contrôleur PID pondéré de précision là-dedans,
vous savez si vous êtes un mathématicien, alors un
muscle est gentil  comme un ressort à
ressort, vous connaissez peut-être la dynamique d'
un ressort
métallique à ressort, étirez-le et écrasez-le,
vous savez qu'il peut être linéarisé autour de
certains points
et vous pouvez ainsi  st à propos d'écrire
un contrôleur LTI PID
pour un must pour un fuseau musculaire individuel
et vous obtiendrez deux paramètres
provenant du cerveau dont l'un dit
la longueur de référence
et l'autre dit que vous savez
quelle est la sensibilité ou le gain contre la
perturbation  que vous devriez faire de l'exercice
et c'est en fait ainsi que vos
mouvements volontaires sont engagés,
donc vraiment
toutes ces choses sur les références dont
nous parlons ici
ne font que mettre en avant l'
hypothèse
que peut-être le contrôle moteur viscéral fonctionne
sur les mêmes principes informatiques et anatomiques
que  le contrôle somatomoteur volontaire,
bien sûr, au lieu des commandes
provenant du cortex somatomoteur,
elles pourraient provenir des ganglions du
système nerveux autonome, le système
nerveux central de niveau supérieur
prescrivant simplement des niveaux approximatifs
d'activation ou de désactivation
d'activité pour les deux côtés différents du
système nerveux autonome
qui, à nouveau, dans cet adversaire de la
mode se  mi-adversaire entièrement La mode coopérative
nous permet d'éviter d'encoder
des nombres négatifs numériques et vous donne ainsi
un contrôle très finement équilibré sur la
milia interne
afin que nous arrivions finalement à notre chiffre
qui dit essentiellement
si je sais quelle ressource fournit
une ressource métabolique fournit des
nutriments oxygène dioxyde de carbone qui
sorte de chose que
je vais avoir à l'avenir,
alors mon objectif ne sera
pas de maximiser l'incertitude
ni de minimiser l'incertitude, mais vraiment
de maximiser la résilience ou la liberté de
rester dans la partie linéaire d'une
fonction de distribution cumulative
où vous pouvez être  sensible
à toute perturbation restante ou à venir
et nous dessinons ici que vous pouvez avoir
cet estimateur de capacité
fermer la boucle
et commencer à diriger les actions motrices via l'
inférence
active afin de suivre cette préférence pour la
résilience contre la perturbation de la
milia interne
qui est alors  lié à l'estimation d'état interceptive
vos autres estimateurs d'état votre a
services de services sensoriels réels
et tout ce schéma de câblage
et peut-être une chose juste à ajouter trop
juste pour souligner un point est
que je pense que si vous revenez en arrière une diapositive
ici
et donc comment cela se rapporte
au type de gamme adaptative de la
décantation  Point aussi et ce que je pense est
vraiment intéressant à propos de ce droit, c'est
que
vous ne définissez pas
comme lorsque nous avons commencé à parler de la
façon dont vous pourriez traditionnellement penser
aux points de consigne pour l'homéostasie dans un
modèle de thermostat très traditionnel
exactement ce dont vous parlez  voici qu'il
y a en fait
[Musique]
euh
si l'objectif global du cerveau si le
cerveau est essentiellement là pour aider à
réguler et à s'adapter à une sorte de
système biologique entier du corps à des
circonstances extérieures qui
vont constamment changer
différents défis  qu'il va
devoir être réactif,
alors vous n'avez pas nécessairement un
point de consigne mais vous avez une
plage où vous pouvez où
où la physiologie peut être  le plus
adaptable à ces perturbations et
défis à droite
et donc
même juste je pense pour simplifier une
sorte de je pense que cette idée est vraiment
au cœur de ce dont nous essayons de parler à
propos de la radio comme ça vous
voulez essentiellement avoir euh
arranger où le  la physiologie peut être
adaptative et oui, vous imaginez que
si la physiologie est si certains de ces
paramètres sont poussés très loin
du centre de ce sigmoïde,
vous allez avoir un problème en
ce sens qu'ils ne pourront pas  adaptez-
vous aux changements que vous êtes, vous ne
pourrez pas être à ce point linéaire d'
adaptabilité maximale si vous êtes ici
près du seuil
et que vous connaissez un bruit blanc aléatoire
qui vous pousse au-dessus de ce
seuil
évidemment là  n'est pas une
panne catastrophique discrète
mais aussi évidemment vous ne pouvez plus
monter une réponse proportionnelle
ouais
votre corps est fait de vous savez des
instruments physiques qui ont
une plage de réactivité limitée
ouais et donc notre notion o  f l'allostase, c'est-
à-dire
quand vous pouvez
élargir la plage de réactivité
plutôt que de la réduire
ou plutôt élargir la plage de
réactivité lorsque cela est possible tout en
réduisant l'ensemble des états ou la
distribution des états dans lesquels vous
tombez réellement ouais
ouais et donc vous avez l'air de faire
des choses quelque peu opposées
et et donc serait-il trop
juste que vous pourriez avoir euh
il y a différentes façons de
faire en sorte que ces systèmes deviennent en quelque sorte inadaptés
si c'est si c'est si ce linéaire
si ce sigmoïde devient de plus en
plus raide et de plus en plus raide où vous fondamentalement
c'est juste une plage très très étroite
où vous pouvez réellement avoir une
réponse adaptative qui peut être un problème potentiel,
un autre problème potentiel peut être
lorsque le type de niveau de référence comme
vous le dites est poussé bien au-delà de
ce seuil,
alors vous êtes aussi  va nécessiter beaucoup
plus de travail et beaucoup plus de contrôles ou
beaucoup plus de contrôle de ce système nécessaire
pour vraiment le pousser loin en dehors de cette
plage  e pour réellement s'adapter pour le
repousser vraiment pour le repousser à nouveau oui,
ce qui pourrait causer d'autres problèmes en
aval également, mais
le fait est juste que vous euh
le genre de plage dans laquelle vous voulez que ce
système s'installe est une plage  où
il peut s'adapter aux changements
et se préparer à des
circonstances fluctuantes,
oui, donc
je pense qu'une bonne intuition à partir du moment où
nous nous apprêtons à dessiner vers la fin
de l'heure
est que
si vous essayiez de minimiser l'
incertitude d'interception
alors quoi  vous pourriez faire est de rester à la maison
tout le temps,
votre fréquence cardiaque ne variera jamais trop de
haut en bas
et nous vivons dans le monde moderne
où vous n'avez pas à fuir les
tigres, vous savez donc pourquoi faire face à l'
incertitude de  sortir et faire de l'exercice
ou la perturbation de sortir et de
faire de l'exercice
et ce que notre notion d'allostase ici
pourrait vous dire en réponse
est de dire que
lorsque vous sortez et faites de l'exercice, la courbe
s'élargit
et donc la plage adaptative où  vous pouvez
monter une réponse proportionnelle
devient plus large,
alors sortez et faites de l'exercice car
cela augmente en fait votre résilience à la
physiologie face au défi physiologique futur,
donc c'est toujours dans l'
ensemble d'intuitions d'inférence active, mais nous
partons vraiment de cette hypothèse que
vous devriez vous préparer de manière préventive
contre un défi possible
plutôt
qu'efficace plutôt que d'agir pour éviter
un défi possible
nous avons déplacé la gestion du défi
dans le corps
euh Dean allez-y alors
que vous atteignez ces extrêmes de ces
moments de crise dont nous parlons un
peu à ce sujet dans le point zéro  comment
l'interaction ou la
proportion d'instruction change-t-elle
entre quelque chose qui est interactif et
et la gamme cherchant à
réintégrer la gamme Je suis curieux de
savoir si les formalismes changent au fur et à mesure que
ces extrêmes sont atteints parce
que, comme vous l'avez dit, les choses ne '  ne
deviens pas toujours
catastrophique tu es irréversiblement
catastrophique
um
stat alors qu'est-ce que tu pourrais aimer en fonction de
ce que tu  ous les gars ont évidemment regardé
ce que vous pensez de la
façon dont cette relation entre l'
interaction et l'instruction change à mesure que
nous atteignons ces limites vraiment dures
euh Jordan tu es souvent un peu meilleur
en physiologie que moi tu veux
prendre ça ou
oh  non, je ne suis pas sûr, je pense que vous pourriez l'
avoir
euh,
alors
voyons
honnêtement, je ne suis pas si bon en physiologie
parce que je compte sur Karen pour cela,
je dirais presque qu'il y a un
échec de territoire de carte ici
où nous essayions de modéliser donc
parler de fonction normale
sous
une fonction normale avec cette intuition
de la résilience contre le défi d'accord
et il y a plusieurs réponses possibles
à une circonstance extrême,
vous savez, l'une est qu'un
mécanisme de contrôle de haut niveau
peut commencer à remplacer
ces points de fonctionnement
en les éloignant de l'endroit où ils
sont normalement et  alors cela vous permet de faire
face à
des circonstances extrêmes en ne les traitant plus du
tout comme des erreurs,
alors dites que si vous êtes malade,
votre température corporelle centrale est  modulé
vers le haut qui vous met dans un état de fièvre,
cela coûte cher sur le plan métabolique et cela
fait mal par rapport à la
façon dont vous fonctionnez normalement, mais cela devrait
cuire les germes
, puis lorsque l'état extrême, vous savez
quand cette urgence est terminée,
j'espère que vous pourrez généralement
pour revenir à la fonction normale,
il y a bien sûr des exceptions telles que, par
exemple, une longue convoitise,
juste pour s'assurer que vous voyez
un changement dans la quantité de
commandes littéralement et la quantité d'allers-
retours à mesure que vous approchez de ces
limites.  pense qu'ils réalisent en quelque
sorte qu'ils se
rapprochent de plus en plus d'
un point de chute
Je pense que c'est en fait une question ouverte et
empirique d'accord, donc l'une des
raisons que nous aimons est allée jusqu'à
écrire un modèle mathématique complet  dans
cet article,
c'est parce qu'ils sont souvent
il n'y a pas beaucoup de
travail neurocomputationnel empirique sur l'
interception, donc si vous posez
des questions très basiques comme
l'interception codée de manière prévisible être  bas
du cou,
c'est encore une question ouverte,
il se pourrait que les périphériques et les
ptéroscepteurs ne fassent que transduire un
signal de stimulus
, puis il n'est encodé de manière prévisible que
lorsqu'il frappe le cerveau que nous ne savons pas
encore, nous préférerions donc avoir un
Eli brièvement perdu nous '  je l'ai perdu mais d'accord
pendant qu'Eli rejoint d'accord très
intéressant
un chemin différent à
travers le même matériel
Dave si votre question est pour Eli nous pouvons
attendre quelques secondes
pas nécessairement
euh j'ai juste un commentaire à côté vous
n'avez pas nécessairement à répondre à
ça  la discussion me rappelle deux
sophismes différents l'un est le
sophisme de la chambre noire vous savez si vous voulez minimiser
c'est une sorte de parodie d'
inférence active si vous ne voulez pas être si vous
ne voulez pas être surpris alors
restez  dans une pièce sombre où rien ne
change, ce qui a été rejeté assez
complètement par des militants actifs de l'assurance
, il y avait aussi une
sorte d'erreur d'interprétation sociale
teintée de
darwiness de l'observation
tha  t chaque espèce a un nombre fixe de
battements de cœur et donc des personnes précieuses, les
membres du parlement et les membres du
clergé, ne travaillaient pas parce que vous mangez
votre vie, ce qui bien sûr
n'est pas vrai parce que votre cœur
bat plus lentement donc il est étiré
plus si vous êtes en bonne forme euh
mais plus pertinent
euh la pente de la courbe réflexe j'ai
parfois l'impression que les gens qui travaillent dans
la
couverture d'inférence active peuvent être trop avec la notion de
précision c'est c'est une quantité
et ça ressemble à la  cette pente dans la
courbe de la pression artérielle euh, mais cela pourrait
être quelque chose qui aurait tendance à être
couvert par le terme précision et si oui,
cela devrait-il être une proportion d'une manière plus
différenciée plutôt que d'
être simplement un nombre unique qui s'applique dans des
lots et des lots de  les zones de contrôle et de
perception
qui sont intéressantes
donc normalement le droit de précision est
normalement appliqué aux prédictions donc
il y a une idée de
la précision de la prédiction  tions
appliquées et dans ce cas, je pense que
l'idée est plus
euh donc ça revient à l'endroit où
vous pourriez parler de
préférences antérieures ciblées dans
les modèles d'inférence active
euh et je pense que la pente de la
courbe de réponse il y a à la place  essayer
de cibler cette utilisation des préférences
précédentes, donc
il essaie de cibler spécifiquement où
est euh
où le système essaie-t-il d'être
navigué, c'est que
oui, quand les gens parlent de préférences antérieures,
ils en ont
parfois parlé en termes de euh
le système ayant  une sorte d'antérior
fort des priors précis forts étant encodés
euh
comme un prior a priori est encodé euh
pour être ciblé
et dans ce cas je pense que c'est euh
nous essayons de rendre compte d'où
certains de ces priors peuvent provenir et
comment ils  systèmes et comment le type de
processus opposés
ou les produits chimiques opposés peuvent aider à
réguler la physiologie
euh
et nous essayons d'avoir une approche plus naturelle
de l'origine de ceux-ci,
donc
bu  t
Je pense euh
si elle est remplacée, j'essaie juste de
penser à parler à haute voix pour réfléchir à la
question, donc
si elle remplace essentiellement une préférence antérieure
et euh
si normalement cette préférence antérieure
serait gérée par euh
une sorte de compte rendu de précision de  c'est
alors dans une certaine mesure la euh
la pente de cette courbe essaie de
s'attaquer euh c'est un peu un remplacement
de la Precision mais
euh
mais ouais c'est euh
c'est ça donne une
façon différente de euh
ouais peut-être que c'est un remplacement pour la
position dans ça  cas
Eli est de retour alors peut-être que je peux essayer de
répondre à votre question Eli voulez-vous
compléter votre présentation
euh bien sûr mais si juste pour répondre à la
question si nous parlons du gain
sur l'une de ces courbes signoïdes
alors
oui c'est une sorte de  remplacement pour
la précision mais c'est vraiment y
penser c'est y penser dans l'autre
sens
donc une variance quantifie votre tolérance
à l'erreur
une précision ou un gain quantifie la
réponse à l'erreur
oui
ouais alors  lorsque vous parlez de signaux purement
sensoriels,
ces signaux réceptifs supplémentaires,
ceux qui ne vous prescrivent
aucune référence,
alors bien sûr, vous savez que vous voulez enregistrer
la réponse neuronale qui est
métaboliquement coûteuse
pour des signaux précis
si vous parlez de  une
courbe physiologique interne, vous savez,
dites réaction à un changement de
pression artérielle,
alors vous voulez essayer de
rendre le gain moins profond, vous voulez
tolérer la variance,
désolé d'
avoir eu
mon modem domestique, je pense qu'il vient de
redémarrer sans raison apparente, nous appelons
ça un  cycle de veille du sommeil
ouais
euh que diriez-vous de faire quelques
mises à jour de gradient de phase de sommeil
mais c'est plus simple c'est rafraîchi
euh c'est prêt pour que vous terminiez la
présentation et ensuite nous
reviendrons très euh intéressant mais
alors d'
accord
euh
voir partager l'écran ici nous allons bien
continuer
ouais alors maintenant nous commençons à
vraiment comprendre le peu de
matériel visuel disponible pour la
section quatre
que je pense que nous devrons examiner en
détail dans un  plus q un format un peu
mais
donc si nous voulons ensuite parler de la façon dont
nous intégrons l'inférence active de décision
dans cette vue allostatique,
nous pouvons dire que la prise de décision est cette
notion de contrôle de contrôle optimal
soumis à un ensemble d'attentes sur
l'avenir,
donc nous  devrons écrire une fonction objective
, puis nous aurons notre schéma de câblage
et nous noterons que les références de moteur
émises de haut en bas
sont maintenant conditionnées ou soumises à des
prédictions sur l'avenir,
puis font partie de la façon dont nous allons obtenir  dans
ce que cette fonction objective est réellement
composée
est de prendre d'abord l'intuition
que si nous partons de circuits neuronaux
qui ne peuvent faire que le traitement prédictif
tel que nous le connaissons,
alors une chose que nous pouvons faire avec eux
est de simuler un ensemble ou une
population
de
trajectoires d'états potentiels ou de trajectoires d'action réellement étatiques à
partir d'un état initial,
alors vous savez, étant donné une
fonction objective,
nous pouvons estimer la moyenne temporelle
compte tenu de notre ense  mble,
nous pouvons transformer cela en contrôle par rétroaction en
obtenant la stabilité dans la théorie du contrôle la stabilité en
boucle fermée dérivée de l'
utilisation de la rétroaction
en ayant ensuite un modèle de reconnaissance
, puis nous pouvons dire ah
je vais mettre à jour tout mon ensemble
ou ma population
de simulations
en les prenant  à partir du
modèle de reconnaissance
qui est conditionnel aux
résultats sensoriels observés
, puis ayant des prédictions à partir de la
densité de reconnaissance
que nous mettons en exposant ici avec un
exposant, vous connaissez aussi les parenthèses
par rapport aux parenthèses en exposant
ici,
nous pouvons alors pénaliser une notion de
distance
donc vraiment nous pouvons  pénalisez la
taille entre guillemets de la mise
à jour en termes théoriques d'information
et si vous avez vu une énergie libre ou une
énergie libre attendue écrite terme par
terme avant que
vous n'ayez dû en voir une, c'est une
divergence KL
mais ce que cela nous donne est  contrôle stabilisé par rétroaction à l'
aide de modèles de probabilité
et qui arrive en fait plus ou moins à
la fin des diapositives par
donc, comme quelques points récapitulatifs, le
modèle informatique
nous donne une notion utile de la concurrence des affordances
,
essentiellement, exécutez un tas de simulations prospectives
choisissez celles qui auront de
bonnes valeurs attendues dans le temps en faisant la moyenne
pour réellement adopter
comme référence motrice
les
courbes sigmoïdales
après avoir pris leurs dérivés pour les
convertir en densités de probabilité,
vous savez, puis en prenant le logarithme de
ceux-ci pour les convertir en densités logarithmiques,
ce qui est beaucoup plus typique car vous connaissez l'
inférence active comme une préférence logarithmique,
ceux-ci fournissent en fait une notion de
monnaie commune
étrangère  parce que maintenant nous avons normalisé vous
connaissez toute la notion de masse de probabilité à
un,
donc une densité sur une variable et une
densité sur l'autre variable ont les
mêmes unités,
nous n'avons plus besoin de notion de
monnaie de récompense dans ce modèle,
alors il y en a  encouragement
pour les anatomistes et les physiologistes à
dire hé
allons regarder la régulation motrice autonome et viscérale
et voir si  nous pouvons le comprendre
en termes de ces circuits de commande de moteur
au niveau bas
et cela nous amène simplement à vous connaître quelques
conclusions très générales,
idéalement notre travail devrait être placé en
dialogue avec vous savez l'inférence active en
tant que travail de contrôle par d'autres auteurs
et bien sûr des remerciements  vous pouvez
vraiment voir ici combien de travail a été
consacré à cela au nom d'absolument tout le monde dans
l'équipe
et les références,
donc j'arrêterai de partager et nous pourrons passer à
un format plus interactif,
génial,
merci d'avoir
partagé cela et alors où était-ce
partagé auparavant  quel contexte
euh juste dans le contexte de notre groupe de laboratoire d'
accord,
alors nous allons faire glisser le groupe College of
Engineering dont nous parlions ouais
ouais donc les diapositives sont vraiment faites pour
ça comme la
psychologie des biologistes avec quelques
groupes d'ingénieurs
cool d'
accord bien  de
nombreuses façons de nombreux chemins à parcourir
juste pour mettre en évidence quelques éléments
sous ce
large parapluie de physiologie un
point important que vous avez soulevé
euh était combien de
hom  eostasis
même
stase
est en effet par rapport à un mécanisme de
fait est que la stabilisation parfois
empiriquement de la stase
et même de l'homéostasie
est que sous Lane par un entraînement à un
point de consigne tel qu'il a été simplifié ou
compris comme dans ce
modèle de thermomètre simple et ensuite dans quelle mesure  apportons-nous l'
excitation de l'hormèse de l'allostase
et différents phénomènes physiologiques
et considérons-les tous comme faisant partie des
engagements homéostatiques dynamiques et multimodaux des corps complexes
par rapport à
um
jeter l'ancien et avec le nouveau et
combien il faut regrouper et diviser la physiologie
même au niveau cellulaire unique  niveau de forme de vie
qu'ils engagent
d'un
point de vue informatique ou théorique de contrôle ou d'information dans des
processus qui sont analogues à certains d'entre
eux
c'est un point que nous pouvons explorer
un autre domaine à explorer est
sur ce thème de ce que font ces systèmes
et comment faisons-nous  modélisez-le le territoire de la carte
ou la
question de recherche fondamentale d'ingénierie um
nous pourrions parler d'un donné
processus physiologique
stabilisation de la température corporelle ou du barorécepteur le
glucose et ainsi de suite
y a-t-il la minimisation d'une
différence
par exemple entre préféré et
observé y a-t-il une maximisation de la récompense
Selon une fonction de récompense
y a-t-il une maximisation de la précision
Précision sur
quoi y a-t-il une maximisation  de réactivité
qui correspond dans la
famille des courbes sigmoïdales à la région linéarisée
y a-t-il des cas où ces quatre
choses vont se produire de manière
indiscernable y a-t-il un cas où certains de ces
phénomènes se produisent au détriment
des autres
pouvons-nous différencier les modèles et en fait
faire des prédictions uniques, des explications et
des systèmes de contrôle
si nous déplaçons notre accent d'une de
ces lentilles à une autre
et comment devrions-nous penser à différents
systèmes physiologiques allant des
mécanismes implicites et très anciens
à ceux qui consciemment peuvent même donner l'impression,
par exemple, d'une récompense de minimisation des erreurs
maximisation
maximisation de la précision maximisation de la réactivité,
donc je vais
m'arrêter là et soit les auteurs peuvent faire
des remarques, soit n'importe qui peut soulever une
question ou penser
Eli, je voulais juste vous demander peut-être juste
de diriger cela parce que vous avez parlé
à la fin de
ce que cela nous apporte  loin
d'avoir une devise de récompense
oh ouais et peut-être que je serais intéressé si
vous pouviez élaborer un peu là-dessus,
alors
juste euh quel serait le rôle typique d'une
devise de récompense et comment
ce genre de comment le le  cadre
que vous proposez de changer cela,
oui, alors vraiment, je reculerais et je dirais que vous
savez ce qui change, c'est le
point de vue de l'inférence active, alors citez sans
guillemets généralement si vous faites
quelque chose comme
euh si vous êtes quelqu'un comme  Yale Neve ou
Sam gershman, alors vous pensez à la
récompense en termes d'apprentissage par renforcement comme
quelque chose que le cerveau doit maximiser
, puis vous diriez d'accord, je
veux que
l'incertitude de mes croyances soit
minimisée  alors que je maximise la récompense,
il s'agit donc de deux calculs modulaires distincts
qui ont des objectifs presque opposés, l'
un d'eux est de minimiser l'
incertitude en ce moment et l'autre est
de maximiser la récompense à long terme
et les revenus, vous connaissez l'inférence active
et dites vraiment non non si vous  formulez cela
comme un problème d'optimisation variationnelle,
alors vous pouvez obtenir un objectif unifié pour
cela
où vous savez que la monnaie commune est pour
ainsi dire
um preuve
vraiment vous savez la preuve que vous
suivez la bonne trajectoire la
preuve que vous exécutez un
comportement commerce correct
et les séries de preuves que vous connaissez en termes de
je suppose que nous les appellerions des moucherons ou des bits
sont les unités et la théorie de l'information, donc
si vous utilisez
vous savez e comme base de votre
logarithme,
ce n'est pas si vous utilisez une base log 2
ce sont des morceaux que
mes chiens sont ramassés pour leurs
promenades, donc
oui, c'est une perspective complémentaire très intéressante
où nous obtiendrons une maximisation des récompenses au fil du
temps
lorsque nous
augmenterons o  ur Précision maintenant tout
le monde est d'accord là-dessus et est-ce que ce sera la
charrette avant le cheval ou le cheval
avant la voiture et lequel est le cheval
et lequel est la charrette
et encadrant la fonction objectif unifiée
en termes théoriques de l'information
comme une heuristique de délimitation surprenante comme  a
été fait dans les limites inférieures de la preuve bayésienne
pendant longtemps en encadrant la
limitation de la minimisation de la surprise comme la
fonction objectif unifiée et la monnaie,
puis il y a le
maintien réalisé de l'homéostasie ou comme nous
voulons appeler cela
sans avoir besoin d'une maximisation traditionnellement
structurée
de la récompense telle que définie par  une fonction de
récompense ou de récompense à prix réduit
et c'est aussi très euh intéressant comme
nous n'essayons pas d'accumuler la température corporelle,
nous n'essayons pas d'
accumuler du glucose
si nous jouions à un jeu où simplement
plus de points valaient mieux
comme certains sociaux et sous-sociaux  games
puis une optimisation unilatérale via la
maximisation Paradigm a beaucoup de
sens
mais pour le genre de ph  ysiological
jeux infinis auxquels nous jouons
comme vous l'avez souligné avec l'horizon infini,
alors il peut être plus logique
d'avoir une responsabilité limitée
et de mettre l'accent sur la contrôlabilité
sous des priors hérités que ces
plages contrôlables sont les
plages de survie sinon comment aurait-on pu
exister pendant des générations
plutôt que  essayez de
Stack Up glucose
ouais donc je pense
qu'il est toujours très intéressant de revenir en
arrière et de lire Peter Sterling sous cet
angle
parce que
vous savez qu'au-delà du
matériel physiologique formel,
il y a ces histoires qu'il peut raconter,
par exemple des personnes vivant dans des
conditions stressantes à long terme  situations
et ils développent ce que nous appellerions maintenant
les maladies de la civilisation
que vous savez que Sterling
implique en quelque sorte sont les maladies de l'homéostasie
vivant trop de la même manière trop souvent
et en effet en parlant de vous savez ne pas
vouloir accumuler de
glucose c'est  que vous savez qu'il s'agit d'une véritable
maladie qui touche les gens et qui
s'appelle le
diabète.  est considérée comme une pathologie et il
y a donc
presque un décalage intéressant
entre cette notion intuitive de récompense
ou du moins
ricanons légèrement et disons cette
notion économique de récompense
qui doit être une forme de
richesse accumulée dans une monnaie commune
par rapport à la physiologie dans laquelle aussi  une grande partie d'une
bonne chose est en fait une mauvaise chose encore une fois
et et cela revient en fait
à si vous y
contribuez en partie, alors d'une certaine manière, c'est une
sorte de changement de métaphore à droite ou c'est
je pense que ce point à propos d'un
une conception et une valeur économiques et de la
récompense
est-
il utile d'avoir un contrepoint à
cela parce que comme Eli le dit,
il n'y a pas de limite supérieure à la récompense économique,
il y a un avantage à l'
accumuler, vous pensez en quelque sorte à accumuler du
capital pour le dépenser
euh
dans ce cas  ce sur quoi nous nous
concentrons, c'est
comment
rester équilibré et adaptable
afin que les défis futurs puissent être
réellement rencontrés et traités et
que parfois  s signifie emballer léger ne pas
garder autant de glucose sous la main afin que
vous puissiez très bien gérer la récompense
ou faire face à des circonstances changeantes et vous y
adapter,
mais vous ne pouvez pas euh
c'est en fait c'est peut-être ouais c'est
peut-être un problème assez sérieux pour
avoir cette
notion complètement abstraite de la valeur
qui
um
est accumulable à l'infini et
ne s'interface en fait avec aucune des
réalités biologiques de um
de ce que les systèmes font réellement là-
bas c'est tellement
abstrait que c'est euh
c'est c'est  va avoir beaucoup de mal à
s'interfacer avec la biologie
ouais avant de passer à la question disons,
résumons cela en disant que les
comptes bancaires sont illimités et qu'ils sont
utiles parce qu'ils sont illimités,
vous savez que le compte comme un économiste
peut concevoir des billions de  dollars en
actifs
d'une manière que mon corps ne peut pas les
corps sont limités
si vous savez qu'ils sont physiquement
limités ils sont constitués d'une quantité finie
de matière à la fois
si  essayez d'en mettre trop plus
quelque chose de mauvais se produira
naturellement après avoir mis cela en place sur cette
discussion de canal, je dois me baisser
un peu plus tôt mais je vais essayer
d'être de retour pour 50.2 la semaine prochaine et je suis
vraiment intéressé de voir où
va cette conversation donc je vais rattraper
les hubs merci
euh d'accord merci
si personne ne me dérange je voudrais d'abord poser sa question à Dave
juste parce que j'étais sur le point de le
faire quand j'ai été
expulsé  c'est Dave
ou euh c'est celui que j'ai dit
euh ouais je sais lequel c'était
euh si tu as une nouvelle question c'est bon
je oh ouais c'est probablement mieux euh
ses deux
morceaux de civilisation il y a la
rumeur et peut-être que c'était juste une erreur
ou un malentendu selon lequel les personnes qui ont
réussi à rester à Londres pendant le
blitz dans des conditions auxquelles on
s'attendrait produiraient une quantité massive de syndromes de conversion d'
hystérie de maladies psychosomatiques psychosomatiques
que cela ne s'est pas
produit, les gens étaient juste absurdement
sains d'esprit parce qu'ils l'ont fait  n'ont pas eu le temps d'être
malades ils n'ont pas eu le temps d'être fous
est-ce que cela s'est vraiment produit est-ce
que le sens de la mission l'a emporté sur ce
qui aurait autrement été le
syndrome de stress général provoquant des pannes
euh quelqu'un connaît-il l'
histoire détaillée du Blitz de Londres dans le monde  War
II parce que je ne sais vraiment pas c'est un super
euh pas anglais dot 1.5
um Journey pour nous d'explorer mais pour en
parler en général
c'est aussi une question intéressante dans
quelle mesure en réconfortant et en
régularisant
nous travaillons même contre cela et encore moins
négliger d'autres compromis et encourir des
externalités
um Dean
Eli cela a été fantastique je donc voici
voici mon truc
euh et je peut-être dans le dans le point
deux nous allons entrer dans le je j'ai
mentionné à la fin du point  zéro
j'étais j'espérais que tu avais
vraiment des gants de velours pour me guider à travers
le 4.4 parce que
et surtout après le contexte que tu
as pu nous fournir aujourd'hui autour de l'
idée que
[Musique]
euh
tu connais des ingénieurs et des psychologues
est entré dans une pièce maintenant, je ne sais pas si
une fois que vous êtes entré dans cette pièce, c'est
devenu une intersection avec un
feu rouge et vous avez en quelque sorte joué à
un Red Rover, allez sur quelque chose ou la
météo et vous le savez si bien
voici  le truc parce que j'ai en fait
travaillé avec des directeurs financiers et des ingénieurs et donc
ce que vous découvrez, c'est qu'il y a un peu d'
isomorphisme, je veux pouvoir schématiser
cela pour vous, voir que cela a tendance à
être biaisé pour les ingénieurs et puis il y a
l'enveloppe spatiale  vue du
psychologue comme s'ils étaient dans leur
espace phénoménologique et ce que vous avez
fait,
c'est que vous avez essayé de dire quoi quoi quand
ces deux mondes se rejoignent Je ne sais pas
si c'est une collision Je ne sais pas si
c'est  une coopération, c'est une variété de
choses, c'est compliqué, nous allons en
rester là, mais ma question est
la suivante lorsque je suis arrivé à 4.4, j'avais l'impression que si
je skiais, je suis passé d'un magnifique
champ de poudreuse à des
arbres peu éloignés jusqu'à Plus serré  et plus serré
et fina  lly j'étais comme je ne sais pas comment
je peux continuer parce qu'il ne
semble plus y avoir de lacunes ici, ça
devient juste trop serré pour moi et la
réconciliation comme quand tu skies
comme métaphore est que tu n'es pas  en regardant
les arbres,
vous regardez la non-chose,
ce sont les non-objets, c'est une
réconciliation
et quand nous parlons de ballon chasseur
comme métaphore ou si nous
parlons de
glucagon, contrôlez-moi ce que
vous décriviez  jusque-là,
vous disiez essentiellement que nous
sachions ce qui se passe nous allons
examiner la gestion des risques nous allons
examiner la coordination nous allons
examiner ces choses qui sont
essentiellement tournées vers l'arrière nous pouvons  dire
que pour que le processus se
poursuive, il doit y avoir une certaine prise en compte
de ces facteurs, puis
il doit y avoir une réconciliation, tout
comme lorsque les ingénieurs et les
psychologues sont proches les uns des
autres, c'est un enchevêtrement et et
ce n'est pas  a les ingénieurs peuvent dire aux
psychologues quoi faire, pas plus que
les psychologues ne peuvent dire aux
ingénieurs quoi faire correctement, donc
si
si l'élément comportemental si l'idée de
la biologie et de la physiologie est si je le
fais maintenant en termes réels
je  je dois regarder ça et vous avez
eu des délais différents pour L4,
je peux gérer que vous avez parlé
clairement de cela, je j'ai lu cela et il
était clair pour moi que j'étais je l'ai compris, je peux
coordonner cela
et encore une fois c'était très très clair et
puis
je suis arrivé à 4.4
et j'ai simplement perdu le fil parce
que ce que je cherchais était la
réconciliation Je vais aligner ce prochain
mouvement avec le récapitulateur de gamme c'est
ce que j'attendais ensuite et alors je suis
allé bien alors où est la stratégie
parce que c'est là  lorsque lorsque des
psychologues et des ingénieurs entrent dans une
pièce, ils n'abandonnent pas simplement leur
stratégie, cela vient avec eux, cela les
suit dans cet espace et les amène à
cette question de je concilie
un avantage et tout ce qui précède jusqu'à
J'ai choisi ce choix tout en
gardant toujours tout ce qui précède, donc vous en avez
parlé dans d'autres parties de celui-ci, vous avez dit que
nous ne pouvions pas simplement l'abandonner
mais je ne pouvais pas comprendre comment le
formalisme l'a
réconcilié,
donc je suis désolé que ce soit si long  -question longue
mais papier photo oh c'est
génial de passer six heures de ma vie à
aller ces gars doivent être beaucoup
plus près de répondre à ça parce que je n'ai
jamais pu y répondre mais ensuite je me
suis perdu et je me suis juste senti comme oh mec
qu'est-ce qui me manque d'
accord, donc
je vais vous décevoir légèrement et
dire que vous savez ce qui vous manque, c'est que
je pense que ce qui manque à notre écriture
est vraiment d'être clair que nous travaillons
sous un ensemble très
inhabituel de contraintes dans la façon dont nous  formulé
ce modèle
si spécifiquement contrairement à dire
Sam gershman Oriel congé
ou contrairement à la littérature sur l'inférence active profonde
dans les ordinateurs,
nous supposons que vous
n'avez essentiellement pas besoin d'
un ensemble supplémentaire d'
ingrédients informatiques pour l'apprentissage par renforcement
, nous disons donc  en supposant que vous ne pouvez effectuer
que les
opérations de calcul connues pour être
impliquées dans le traitement prédictif,
que pouvez-vous proposer qui
résoudra un problème de contrôle
et la réponse est cette chose très spécifique
avec ces dérivations désagréablement impliquées
appelées contrôle intégral de chemin
et vous remarquerez  que lorsque je
parcourais ces diapositives, j'ai essentiellement dit
disons simplement que vous pouvez simuler
des futurs
possibles comme des cours de durée d'épisode possibles, vous
connaissez des cours d'activité future
et vous pouvez les évaluer en termes de
votre fonction objective
, puis vous pouvez les mettre à jour par  au moyen d'
un modèle de reconnaissance
ou en intégrant des erreurs de prédiction et en
utilisant un codage prédictif,
alors comment pouvons-nous construire un formalisme à partir
de celles-ci
et l'avantage est que cela nous permet de
regarder la littérature sur les contrôles et de dire
que c'est en fait
un contrôle optimal stabilisé par rétroaction
nous pouvons examiner une partie de la
littérature
sur la rationalité limitée dans les sciences cognitives et les neurosciences
et sa  y notre fonction objective est une énergie libre,
c'est-à-dire
si vous devez pénaliser à quel point vous
modifiez le déclenchement neuronal au
fil du temps
ou à quel point vous changez d'avis et
mettez à jour vos croyances au fil du temps
parce que vous n'avez qu'une quantité limitée de
puissance métabolique dans votre tête,
alors nous incluons  un terme de pénalité pour cela
et nous pouvons dire que tout cela peut simplement être fait
par vous savez la simulation incarnée et
le contrôle moteur de la configuration de référence
cela signifie-t-il que c'est ainsi que le cerveau
fait réellement les choses, bien sûr,
vous ne savez pas que cela signifie que si vous
voulez faire  votre modélisation avec
je pense
euh Andy Clark a tendance à citer que vous connaissez
Quine et à dire si vous voulez faire si vous
avez un goût pour les paysages du désert,
alors nous vous avons donné un modèle informatique
qui est essentiellement juste des roches sablées
et en tant que tel oui c'est quelque chose  d'un
environnement hostile
tu sais marcher sans Rhythm tu n'enlèveras pas
le ver
dans les plans d'actif
ouais si tu veux vivre derrière le
mur de bouclier où nous avons
euh la
valeur estimée TD fonctionne bien  pour
vous
dans le sigmoïde étiré avec une large
variabilité si étirée qu'elle est plate
et simple mais toujours hautement
contrôlable dans de grandes limites,
c'est là que nous
oscillons oui
très intéressant ce sera, je pense, génial
dans notre laboratoire pour ramasser quelques points  de
suis-je celui qui coupe à nouveau
je te vois toujours ouais
c'est bon ouais tu es de retour bien tu as
clignoté un peu d'accord
euh dans les dernières minutes nous pouvons
parler de quelques idées plus tôt dans
le journal regarde n'importe lequel des chiffres et
puis dans le point deux ce sera génial
d'aborder vraiment le formalisme et d'
aider Dean sur ce voyage de ski
euh
ce qui serait quelque chose à faire dans
ces dernières minutes
oui Dean et juste et Eli peut-être que je
pourrai avoir une chance  pour élaborer avec
ce peu plus de Jordan dans le prochain,
mais je suis curieux que vous vous vous soyez donné beaucoup de mal et que vous soyez
excellent à Great Lengths pour dire regardez,
cela ne correspond pas directement à toutes les
complexités dont nous savons qu'elles existent, mais pourquoi
parce que vous l'avez dit  commencer par ça dans
20  19 vous aviez un peu de temps libre
et puis et puis vous avez en quelque sorte fait allusion à
cela au début
, y avait-il des découvertes que vous avez faites
que vous n'aviez pas anticipées
parce que vous étiez très aussi très euh
respectueux envers qui vous reconnaissiez comme une
sorte de  en jetant les bases ici,
vous aviez un peu de stabilité pour travailler,
mais vous êtes-vous retrouvé
à découvrir des choses
qui n'existaient pas avant que vous ne vous
réunissiez autour de cela et pensez-vous que
cela continue d'évoluer ou le fait-il
restez juste à un niveau théorique
[Musique]
euh,
donc en fait, je dirais que pour moi personnellement,
la grande découverte imprévue était à
quel point nous en savons
peu sur la neuroanatomie et la neurophysiologie interceptives
et je veux dire à la périphérie, donc
vous connaissez notre laboratoire avec Lisa et Karen
Lisa  gère les choses au-dessus du cou
et donc nous vous avons fait connaître Barrett et
Simmons 2015 il y a un certain nombre d'autres
bons articles disant essentiellement que vous
regardez l'architecture du cerveau et cela
ressemble à  moins dans le cortex,
vous savez que les cortex moteurs interceptifs et viscéraux
sont assez centraux dans l'
architecture, puis vous demandez d'accord, donc
quels types de signaux arrivent de
la périphérie
pour ensuite être soumis à un traitement prédictif
dans le cortex
et vous êtes essentiellement bien informé en
terreceptif  signaux évidemment
donc il y a eu ce moment où je
travaillais avec Karen et j'ai réalisé oh d'accord
donc
il semble qu'il y ait en fait cette
analogie étroite que nous pourrions émettre l'hypothèse
entre
la fonction connue d'un circuit somatomoteur
pour le contrôle moteur volontaire
et cette façon de gérer la fonction réflexe de Barrel
et il semble que pour le réflexe de barillet,
vous savez que vous pouvez modifier volontairement le
gain ou la tolérance, ceux-ci étant
inverses l'un de l'autre,
changer le point de fonctionnement que vous connaissez
volontairement ne semble pas se produire, mais
il semble se déplacer
et il commence à regarder  comme si ah
nous pouvions juste nous pouvons arrêter de dire que
vous savez qu'il y a des signaux d'interception
nous ne savons rien  à leur sujet
et demandez à la place comment pourrions-nous décomposer
le système nerveux autonome et la
périphérie interceptive en ces
circuits de contrôle, vous savez, où il y a
une référence qui coule d'en haut
ou est éventuellement intégrée en tant qu'avant,
puis un capteur, puis un motoneurone  ou
un effecteur
qui, encore une fois,
spécule totalement, on pourrait imaginer que la boucle
pourrait être ultra locale
ou même obtenir des jonctions électriques cellulaires
aussi locales que possible pour
fermer la boucle de contrôle du moteur, puis
il y aurait potentiellement une échelle plus méso
purement à la périphérie
euh peut-être  une sorte d'
actions de type coordination motrice ou vasoconstriction qui
sont mises en œuvre via des
réseaux de neurones locaux et d'autres systèmes, puis lorsque
vous devez appeler le système
nerveux central
et vous engager à ce niveau,
c'est la plus grande capacité de
calcul de mémoire intermodale tous ces
autres  des phénomènes complexes qui peuvent alors
être considérés comme ayant leur juste place
peut-être même dans un cerveau spécifique  région,
mais l'ensemble de la performance intégrée du dodgeball
ne sera pas plus localisé dans une
région du cerveau qu'il ne le serait
au bout d'un doigt,
car tout doit être coordonné
et tous les appels ne peuvent pas être locaux
et tous les appels ne peuvent pas être globaux, donc
trouver  comprendre comment les corps en tant que territoires
et nos modèles en tant que cartes
relient les
choses vont rendre les modèles plus
interprétables
mieux alignés avec les données empiriques
faisant des prédictions et des explications plus utiles
c'est un angle très intéressant
et je dirais juste pour vous greffer un
peu vous savez en tant que  modélisation Paradigm Je
pense que c'est l'une des vraies forces
de l'inférence active,
c'est qu'une fois que vous avez affaire à ces
densités de probabilité et log
densités de probabilité,
vous êtes en
mesure de commencer à esquisser ces
structures hiérarchiques
et cela ne signifie pas que chaque
inférence active hiérarchique  le modèle est
automatiquement une carte du système nerveux
mais cela signifie que vous avez un
langage qui est au moins minima  parfaitement
capable d'exprimer ce que nous trouvons si
abondamment dans les preuves empiriques
ouais une partie de l'
article qui était très intéressante ce que nous avons
remarqué en le lisant,
bien que la plupart des articles soient écrits avec des
mots, celui-ci était très avancé
chaque section avait un
résumé du contenu du préambule
technique de sandwich comme l'a fait le papier
à une échelle plus élevée, la nomenclature
était claire et claire, puis la
relation entre les
distributions cumulatives et les
densités de probabilité de type PDF classique
a été clarifiée, mais cela
relie exactement
quelque chose qui a un um
dans le cas générique
un garanti  point d'inflexion
valeurs seuillées interprétables c'est
pourquoi les fonctions sigmoïdes sont utilisées comme
fonctions d'activation dans
les réseaux de neurones artificiels
avec
une approximation laplacienne optimisable euh
comme la
forme quadratique inversée
qui peut être utilisée comme une
probabilité logarithmique et donc vraiment comme
surtout avec la figure 9
montrant le pas à pas  relation
ouvre la porte à aimer hé si vous  'ai
vu un sigmoïde quelque part
maintenant, vous pouvez y penser comme un
PDF masquant une courbe en cloche PDF
, puis là où vous avez vu une
courbe gaussienne ou en cloche ou une approximation laplacienne,
vous pouvez aller dans l'autre sens et
y penser en termes de
action de réponse sigmoïdale
et donc ils sont rarement connectés aussi
clairement
bien que ceux qui sont familiers c'est
presque l'eau dans laquelle ils nagent et
ceux qui ne sont pas familiers ne verraient pas
la connexion
et le défi et l'
opportunité est comme rester au
milieu
et rester
dans l'espace de connexion
pour attirer l'attention sur certaines de ces
relations qui, encore une fois, sinon vous
pourriez avoir tout un sous-domaine de la
physiologie travaillant sur la
courbe de réponse sigmoïde et tout un sous-domaine de modèles de
traitement prédictif hiérarchique
travaillant dans l'espace PDF ou l'espace log
PDF
et c'est juste  une dérivée et un log ou
une exponentiation et une dérivation loin
de ces deux champs étant formellement
connectés non seulement comme un spéculatif  e
article de révision, quelqu'un pourrait ou devrait le faire,
mais comme c'est fait, nous ne connaissions tout simplement pas les
outils, donc je pense qu'en ce qui concerne l'écriture, je
dois vraiment remercier Lisa et
Karen pour beaucoup de choses où
vous savez parler de parler de
dialectique  processus vous savez que nous avons une
dialectique d'écriture très simple sur ces
articles qui est l'auteur junior connaît les mathématiques
les auteurs seniors
ne se sont pas spécialisés en mathématiques dans leur
premier cycle ou maîtrise ou clé ou
même doctorat, même s'ils sont bons avec ça
maintenant
et le résultat finit par être  vous savez
qu'on vous dit toujours de revenir en arrière et d'
expliquer chaque étape et bien sûr
Jordan, vous savez qui était ici avant,
aidait beaucoup à l'écriture, à la
structuration et à la signalisation
, puis
je pense que l'insight réel que
vous  peut prendre l'un de ces sigmoïdes et le
transformer en PDF,
je pense que c'est après avoir
martelé nos têtes sur une partie de la
littérature sur le traitement prédictif incarné un tas de fois
étrangère,
c'est l'une de ces choses t  hat est
littéralement incarné
Dean
ouais je voulais juste mettre ça dans I I
Ce qui m'a attiré vers le journal en
premier lieu, c'est que l'affaire Alice
descendait et l'interception qui
m'a fait y revenir était
euh
et nous en avons parlé dans le  le point zéro
était un
guide qui règle euh des
échanges de perspective parfaits par rapport à un
classeur lorsque j'ai commencé à lire cet
article, j'ai vu la métamorphose de l'
identification d'un moyen de trouver des choses et maintenant
après avoir eu cette conversation avec vous
aujourd'hui et et Jordan et bien sûr l'
habituel le soupçonne  il est plus clair
pour moi que ce document essaie de jouer
ce rôle d'
identifiant de perspective d'orientation par opposition à nous avons
trouvé le moyen ou c'est c'est notre façon
de résoudre tous les maux du monde, ce qui
bien sûr je ne le pense pas  était toujours votre
intention, mais lorsque vous tirez des choses qui
sont apparemment assez éloignées comme l'
allostase et l'interception,
je suis excité mais je ne le fais pas comme vous l'avez
souligné, pomper la vapeur de frein ne
devient pas  trop excité ici, je veux dire que nous faisons de
notre mieux, donc à ce niveau, euh,
mon amygdale fonctionne toujours
correctement
dans nos dernières pensées avec un
exemple de conduite, accumulons
-nous de la vitesse ou minimisons-nous
le temps ou nos limites de vitesse
même définies comme extériorisées
les bonnes normes et les marques stigmergiques sur la
niche de
sorte qu'une variété de voitures, d'une
voiture de sport à un 18 roues, peuvent se trouver dans
une zone de contrôlabilité optimale en
tenant compte de la présence de passages
pour piétons, etc., à mesure que nous réfléchissons
à ce que nous  veulent explorer dans le point
deux parallèlement à la plongée dans les formalismes en
essayant de faire des
fouilles et des interceptions
sur comment et où
l'optimisation économique en tant que
maximisation
est implicitement utilisée
et où certaines de ces autres notions
qui ont été soulevées
sans avoir besoin d'être polémiques ou de
remplacer la maximisation de la valeur
mais où nous pouvons voir
ces autres
critères de capacité de survie
comme des décompositions potentiellement différentes
de fonctions objectives unifiées qu'un  re
informatif et ainsi de suite,
je pense que cela va être
assez vaste
parce qu'il y a plus de situations dans
lesquelles je m'aventurerais où nous préférerions avoir la
contrôlabilité et la limitation des attentes
et la réunion
plutôt que l'empilement de points,
donc les commentaires finaux que vous aimez
oui, donc je veux juste vraiment fermer
en soulignant à nouveau que
nous ne savons pas que nous ne le sommes pas,
je pense que j'ai cette blague sur mon
profil Twitter, abolissez la fonction de valeur et
c'est vraiment juste un jeu de mots pour les personnes
qui peuvent l'obtenir, mais vous savez que nous n'essayons pas
pour dire aux gens contrairement à leur
expérience subjective oh vous n'avez pas
vraiment de
valeur dans votre cerveau il y a en
fait juste vous savez essayer de suivre
votre trajectoire de référence
donc dans la 0.2 nous pouvons parler de vous savez
quels types spécifiques de rétroaction contrôlent
quels types  des mécanismes de rétroaction sont
vraiment évoqués dans cet article
et je pense que, comme
vous le savez, c'est négatif à la fois
négatif dans le sens d'éviter le
renforcement négatif et dans le sens
o  f essayer d'aplatir une
fonction de réponse et être capable de répondre proportionnellement
afin que vous sachiez avec le
recul que
cet article va avoir un
domaine d'application assez limité,
mais il est utile en ce sens qu'il nous donne un
langage vers lequel nous tourner  l'ex aux
empiristes et dites que c'est ce que nous
voulons réellement rechercher pour
tous les commentaires de clôture sinon c'est une
bonne note
bien Eli et Jordan aussi merci d'être
venus et de vous être engagés dans dot
Winery et nous vous verrons la semaine prochaine
merci les gars  à la semaine prochaine